speaker this boy is my colleague in
computer science at our rental hm thanks
for having me here so so I want to talk
about something about like mathematical
modeling the to said that computer
scientist and many as a quantitative
like field researchers in the
quantitative field tends to use and the
intricacy is related to thinking about
how to do a mathematical model so I will
use the labor market as an example and
this is based on John work with lady who
I think wow she she's here now so I want
to start by talking about a very simple
model that's try to explain
discrimination in labor market so this
model arises from the economics
literature where people try to explain
why there's persistent like discrepancy
discrepancy between like minority group
and majority group people in terms of
wage and the like the percentage that
are hired by companies scoot jobs so
bear with me this is going to be a very
simple model and at the end so all
models has abstractions but the hope is
that the abstraction leaves something
important related to the problem in the
model such that we can make inference
about the problem and say something so
let me just start by thinking that there
are two sub populations so the blue
people and the right people they're
bound to have roughly equal abilities
and I'm very weak about what I mean by
ability because I want to make a
distinction for the next step so they're
essentially you can think about that
their population wise or Bom Iko in
terms of the how they can learn how much
effort they're willing to exert an oath
of set of things and then the
individuals of the population they
choose to invest in human capital so
those other things about how they choose
to get education they learn new skills
some of them become codified for some
skilled job so I use the shaded circles
to represent those individuals that
become codified as a result of this
investment in the human capital and I'm
trying to differentiate between the
ability and the qualification of the
individuals and knowingly know that this
is impossible to really tell them apart
in practice so this is the abstraction
okay but what is known by a firm who's
offering jobs that requires some skills
is that they don't they do not know the
individual qualifications so for each
individual they don't know whether the
individual is codified or not but what
they do observe is the job percentage of
the people in a sub population that's
qualified or not so so for example the
blue population are qualified with
eighty percent of people and the red
population is Caliphate only was twenty
percent of the people and you can think
about this comes from historical data or
just to the beliefs of the firm's and
then what's going to happen is that so a
Caliphate individual can exert some
effort and have an observable signal and
that's going to be correlated with
whether his Caliphate or not
so because I said that whether
individuals qualified or not that's not
observable by the firm but this signal
which is correlated with the Caliph
Acacia of the individual is observable
and we also know that oh so if an
individual is qualified then the
probability for that individual to
receive a good signal is going to be
higher compared when if the individual
is now qualified then that probability
of receiving a good signal is going to
be lower so so now I have the two
populations of the people fundamentally
some individuals are codified but that's
not observable but then they have some
observable signals
that's good Oh bad for example here and
then it comes to the hiring decision of
the firm so a firm cannot really observe
whether individual is codified or not
but the firm can observe the signal so
for individual come from the blue
population and receiving a good signal
so the firm can observe the group
identity and the signal that this
individual has and then if the firm is
just a rational agents doing Bayesian
reasoning he's going to calculate the
probability that given a blue person
that has received the good signal what's
the probability that this blue person is
actually coalified for the skilled job
and similarly given a red person that
has received the good signal what's the
probability that this red person is
qualified for the job and the way that
is set up this simple model because
there is initial distribution
differences and it's more likely for a
codified person to receive a good signal
and by Bayesian rule we can just
conclude that oh if it's a blue person
who has a good signal then the
probability that this person is
qualified is going to be higher for
compared with the red person who has
exactly the same signal so it just seems
to be that it's a rational decision for
the firm to jaw and saying that oh I
should hire the blue person with a good
signal with higher probability than a
right person with a good signal oh I
should set the wage for the blue person
to be higher so I can roughly think
about that I can set the wage equal to
the expected productivity of an
individual that I decided to her
so the signal so the signal could be
some performance I'm a prior job for
example and the human capital accusation
could be an investment in learning some
skills so so this is a abstraction I'm
not trying to say that this captures
everything about labor market and that's
the whole part this is the simple
abstraction but this model looks very
benign in the sense of there is no
preference based discrimination because
the decision-maker does not already have
a preference over one group of people
compared with the other group of people
and the decision-maker seems to be very
rational and just too trying to
inference based on who is more likely to
be caliph I'd what is the problem of
this model you may say that oh this
prior information is that wrong so the
bias comes into the model through here
because the historical data may be
biased and hence when this information
is biased
oh the inference can be wrong but in
fact once we have a model like this it
is a self-fulfilling prophecy that the
data being generated can be consistent
with this model so let me try to explain
what does it mean so if we look at a red
in the video who's qualified the
probability for him going to be hard is
going to be lower compared with a blue
individual who's qualified only in other
words the wage that is right in the
video going to receive is going to be
lower than the wage that a blue
qualified individual is going to be
received and when an individual trying
to make decisions on the human capital
acquisition the individual are going to
do a cost-benefit analysis so
the cost-benefit analysis basically will
say that oh the benefit for blue in the
video is going to be higher as no
benefit for a right individual to invest
in human capital and become qualified
alrighty
in favor of the blue group and also we
can interpret this as the social
reputation and has the cost of acquiring
the investing in human capital can also
be different for individuals from this
two different group so usually it's less
costly for a blue individual to invest
in human capital than for a red in the
video to invest in human capital so what
it means is that they're going to be
mild blue people choose to invest in
human capital and become qualified then
the individuals that are right from the
red group so that basically saying that
oh we have a feedback from the hiring
decision back to the individual decision
making and this actually confirming the
initial belief that there are more blue
people that are qualified so this could
be very accurate to represent the data
and was actually happening in the
reality so so this is a little bit
puzzling it basics is raises the
question of how should I think about the
boundary of my model so if I want to do
analysis for Oh what is the determinate
discrimination in the labor market where
should I draw the boundary of my model
so for example I can draw the boundary
of my model here Krista's saying that
this is a data the historical data and
these are all the information that I
have and I'm making use of the
information that I have try to make the
best decision so I am a rational
decision maker I don't have preference
over a particular group I'm just in
asymmetric information situation because
I cannot perfect observe the color
vacation of the individuals I'm trying
to make my inference and if I draw the
boundary of my model here so this
actually seems to be pretty good because
it is the case that there are more
people that are codified than red people
and I capture that and my distinction
also capture that so it in some sense
satisfied maybe a notion of group
fairness that computer scientists tends
to think about okay
but this is also deeply troubling
because for an equally good right in the
video he's now being treated in the same
way as a qualified blue in the video so
at the individual level this is not fair
and where I draw the boundary of the
model also relates to like how we ask
the fairness related questions so for
example if they think about what outcome
we really hope to achieve in the labor
market
so in general speaking people will say
that it's equality of opportunity but
there are two views of equality of
opportunity so when is the far more
equality of opportunity basically just
saying that oh we should advertise the
position to all people and then people
can compete for the position and the
better qualified candidate should be
hired
so which in some sense my model does
achieve that so I'm opening the position
to ever won and I'm hurrying based on
the qualification but this is student
deeply troubling because my two
population of people starting with
roughly equal ability although I'm not
trying to precisely define what do I
mean by equal ability but there is a
difference between what they bomb to
have versus what they can do after they
have invested in human capital so so
when there are about the two populations
are roughly
Iko but we ended up with the asymmetric
outcome so the other notion of equality
of opportunity is substantive equality
of opportunity that basically means that
oh if people roughly starts with the
same ability and they are willing to
exert the same level of effort and use
that ability then their prospect of
success should roughly be eco and if we
take that view of what we want to
achieve as the outcome of the labor
market the previous model doesn't
achieve that and we should try to think
about expanding the boundary of the
model by including the feedback loop
here so we need to explicitly think
about how individuals are going to make
their decisions with respect to a
particular employment rule here okay so
so that's a I think that's the first
opponent one who make is kind of tricky
to really think about what is the
boundary of a mathematical model and
what we include in your model and if
you're willing to expand the model to
considering the human decision-making
the individuals decision-making in the
human capital acquisition then we can do
a different kind of analysis so we can
think about that the observed is the
metric outcomes are equilibrium result
of a dynamic game and what we observed
as discrepancy are essentially saying
that the game reaches the equilibrium
point and it's very difficult for
individual to deviate from that
equilibrium so this is from a game
theoretic perspective trying to think
about the problem but then the question
is that if we really want to achieve the
substantive equality of opportunity what
can we do other interventions that we
can do to drive the system toward better
outcome so better means a really
substantive equality of opportunity here
okay so if I consider the bigger model
we're actually can think about the
dynamics here and what we can do so we
think about the the normal labor market
as a dynamic game so there are two
groups of workers and each workers bound
into one of the two groups and then
workers makes investment decision about
like their human capital investment and
then they enter the labor market and
firm makes a hiring decision and worker
produces observable outcomes and that
observed outcomes contributes to a group
reputation for that group and the firm's
can make use of the group reputation and
try to update the group reputation and
then we're back to the next generation
of the workers so that's one way of
thinking about the just a one stage
labor market in a dynamic setting what
we can do is we can have a do labor
markets that have so by introducing a
temporary labor market
so after worker makes their human
capital investment decisions they enter
a temporary labor market where firm
makes hiring decisions and we can have
some intervention here okay and then a
workers exert effort on the job in
temporary labor market it produces some
outcomes then they enter a permanent
labor market but now the firm's can make
hiring decisions solely based on the
observations of the produced outcome and
there is no restrictions and then
workers exert effort on the job in that
permanent labor markets produces
outcomes that affects their group
reputation and this just to continue
indefinitely so we can think about like
if we have a temporary labor market as
an intervention then whether it's
possible for us to like essentially move
the system out of the undesirable
equilibrium and maybe leading toward a
more stable outcome in the future and if
half the intervention just as saying
that we require a statistical parity
hurry in the temporary labor market
which basically means that the
probability that an individual is hired
is conditionally independent of her
group membership so essentially we're
forcing a population-wise parity here
for the temporary labor market and so
just to do that temporarily then the
statistical parity hurrying in the
temporary labor market it ensures
equitable representation with respect to
the ability
so the original ability of the two
groups of populations but not with
respect to their qualifications so even
if one group have more people who are
qualified so this does not like satisfy
parity with respect to the codifications
so and there's no restriction about how
firms choose to make their hiring
decision in the permanent labor market
so they can do whatever that's optimal
for them so if we do this and think of
model like this then what we can show is
that oh there exist a unique group
symmetric steady-state so essentially
the innovative reputations fading into
the group reputations and that produced
externalities that affects the group's
future generations cost of investing in
human capital and that essentially will
lead to a state where two groups are
being hired equally with respect to
their ability but a caveat here is that
this is the existence without we're now
claiming that this will be rich too soon
and we actually don't know how long this
steady state will be reached and it's
also under some conditions this type of
like intervention can produce a welfare
that's better than a group blind hiring
strategy here so that's basically what I
want to talk about and I'm now trying to
claim that the broader model is
the right model it's just a model trying
to consider a little bit more of the the
social intricacies in the labor market
and the labor market itself is situated
in a bigger social system so for people
with technical toolbox that likes to use
mathematical modeling I think a question
that we now asking ourselves is that
where should the boundary of abstraction
be to be because when we want to do
theory we need abstraction for
tractability but we also aware that oh
the abstraction those are ignoring a lot
of important social expects of the
problem so I think this is something
that really need interdisciplinary
effort to try to figure out when
algorithms Oh abstractions and
mathematical models can be helpful in
this domain thank you very much so it
was very interesting
I have a question wouldn't it be easier
to subsidize the workers investment
decision today it could be there may be
either I mean I think that's probably
what's done now I know that they provide
extra programs and training for people
in group sitter I think the other caveat
is that already now comparing different
ways those like different alternatives
of intervention and try to say that very
interesting yeah I think it's thank you
very interesting to think about and it's
also like there is technical limitations
with this type of analysis about how
tractable we can get so
that's what we've been doing for the
most part I have to mirror it or move it
around
you want you can move it into the I'm
just trying it's not my Thank You
Cynthia
it's really been a terrific workshop I
want to thank all the organizers for the
opportunity to participate I've been
learning a lot and I want to tell you a
little bit or talk to you about how we
can talk about human categories in human
kinds and causal analysis and causal
modeling and I'm still a bit of a
dilettante in this topic and this isn't
sort of complete work and I don't have
the answers really I mostly want to
start a dialogue with you and and and
you sort of have the opportunity to
learn from you about some of these
topics and so you know this was
basically the fairness community in 2016
so there were a lot of issues in the
fairness community and people were like
you know it seems that causality sure
would be you know a good fix for a lot
of the problems that we're facing it
seems like so that was a match made in
heaven between you know the sort of
questions of discrimination
decision-making and causality and a lot
of people started thinking about
causality and fairness I was one of them
and there were a bunch more that in 2016
had that sort of inclination so it's
2019 now and you know you know it's we
don't really you know we kind of stared
into the abyss and it stared back at us
and we don't have all the answers and in
particular we haven't solved all the
problems that we thought cause Ellie
might solve and and I'm gonna try to
reflect a little bit on why I think we
haven't solved all the problems that we
want to solve with causality and I'm
gonna focus on a single question even
though there are more facets to it but
the question I'm going to focus on is
what do we actually mean when we put
categories such as race or gender and a
causal model and make causal claims
about it this is a question I've been
exploring for some time now okay and
since this is Berkeley I'm gonna give
you an example that you know torture you
one once more with it you know you've
probably seen this many times before I'm
gonna have a pivot of a different spin
on it so UC Berkeley grad
missions from this famous paper by
Bickle at all from 1975 sex spies and
graduate admissions data from Berkeley
measuring bias is harder than is usually
assumed and the evidence is sometimes
contrary to expectations that was the
title and the data from Berkeley showed
that there was a male acceptance rate of
44% in graduate admissions and a female
acceptance rate of 30% in graduate
admissions at least when you look at the
top six departments I like to look at
the top six departments because they all
have large numbers we're not don't have
to worry about sample fluctuations what
not top by size the sides just like
number of applicants like a moment of
imprecision all right okay largest by
size okay
and so I'm not labeling them so I don't
derail this discussion but basically
what happened so basically the story
here was you might from these acceptance
rates you might prove worried that
there's discrimination against female
applicants because the acceptance rate
is lower and then you look at it at the
department level and Bickel argued well
departments have autonomy over who they
admit and so you should look at this at
the department level and there you see
that for the largest department actually
the acceptance rate was 82% for women
and 62% for men and the second largest
was a 68 percent form and and only 60
percent for men then there were in the
third largest there was a little bit of
an advantage for men 37 to 34 then was
35 to 33 and 28 to 24 and 7 to 6 but you
can see from this data if you sort of
disaggregate the data and you look at
the department level you don't see a
bias in favor of men generally at the
department level so at the department
level it seems to have sort of the trend
seems to have reversed that acceptance
rate is is generally a bit higher for
women and so bikal hadn't told sort of
had an explanation for this and their
explanation was this ok so they are they
wrote the bias in the aggregated data
stems not from any pattern of
discrimination on the part of the
admissions committees which seems quite
fair on the whole but apparently from
prior
screening at earlier levels of the
educational system women are shunted by
their socialization and education toward
fields of graduate study that are
generally more crowded less productive
of completed degrees and less well
funded and that frequently offer poorer
professional employment prospects so
basically his explanation was that women
applied to more competitive departments
and hence get rejected a lot more than
men who applied to less competitive
departments and he is reserved arguing
that it's a bit of a pipeline problem
whatever the interests are in department
choice women seem to have interests in
more competitive departments and so this
was sort of the argument that stood at
the time and was sort of convincing
enough for this case to sort of be
considered resolved and was picked up by
a Judea pearl in his wonderful book from
2009 the textbook causality and he kind
of endowed this pickle explanation with
a causal story a causal explanation and
he said the way you would model is from
a causal perspective is that there are
three variables gender department choice
and admissions outcome and he stipulated
that this causal graph that gender and
causally influences admission in some
direct path but there is an indirect
path by which it influences the
admissions outcome that goes through
Department okay so just as a note since
some of you and cos will speak what this
means is that department choice mediates
the influence of gender on admission so
Department would be called a mediator
but since some of you haven't seen these
causal graphs let me just give you sort
of one slide on how you should read this
so causal diagrams are network of
interactions they tell you who listens
to whom okay so a causal error from X
into y means that the the variable Y
listens to X so if you somehow you know
if X varies so does Y and slightly a
little bit more or maybe more formally a
causal arrow as a placeholder for some
mechanism by which in this case
department choice is determined by
gender up to exogenously ation so what
this means is you could write Department
choice as a function just a
deterministic function of gender and
some noise variable that's independent
of
Department that models exogenously this
is how how you should read these these
diagrams and if you have more than two
incoming arrows
it just becomes a function of the
incoming variables okay so for instance
admission would be a function of
Department gender and some other noise
variable that's independent of
everything so this is how you should
read these causal graphs they tell you
how you can piece together the data or
the these variables and what is kind of
the dependent structure among these
variables so returning to this what
pearl argued is that discrimination
should really be considered this link
the direct link of you know that goes
from gender to Admissions that's sort of
like how admissions actually directly
use gender and this the indirect
influence that goes to the department
choice should be considered okay because
it expresses sort of you know
preferences but of the that the
applicant has that might depend on
gender and so as an aside this is not
the point I'm gonna make but this this
explanation always bothered me a great
deal like it never seemed like at all
satisfactory to me for instance you
could be hiding a lot of weird stuff in
this indirect path that goes through
Department choice
what if really that one edge is not one
edge but it's actually a factor like
fear of a department fear of being
discriminated or isolated in a
department that shapes your department
preference maybe you're like not
applying to that department because
you're worried that you'll be the only
woman in that department or that
department has a bad track record of how
it treated women in the past and so I'm
not sure we should be quite that ready
to like discount this indirect influence
that goes to the department because it
could really look like this or many
other ways okay but this is just my sort
of quick way of saying that I'm not okay
with normatively describing
discrimination as a direct effect of the
sensitive category on to the decision
outcome I think that's much too narrow
view if anything that could capture
something like this pair of treatment
but it cannot sort of address a broader
perspective of discrimination and so I'm
not happy with this but that's not the
point of this talk that's a separate
story that I'm happy to talk to you
about what is my point is you know if we
return to this original graph how should
we read how
we interpret how should we conceptualize
gender as a cause in this causal graph
and so how do we find the direct effect
of gender on admission and I'm just
gonna give you some quotes from pearls
excellent book the book off why if you
haven't read this it's quite quite an
excellent introduction to to causality I
like it quite a bit and he picked up
this Berkeley Admissions example again
and discussed it in more detail and here
is how he tells you you should get at
the direct effect we get the direct
effect of X on Y when we wiggle X your
gender without allowing em here a
department to change and then he says we
hold constant a variable Department and
then tweak the variable gender I'm not
sure I can even talk about tweaking and
wiggling gender variables in public and
I don't know which is worse to tweak or
to avail them and so I'm gonna leave
that behind at this point but it shows
you just how hard it is even for
somebody who's thought about this a lot
to articulate exactly what we mean by
gender being a direct cause of something
right and so we rephrase this that's a
little bit a page later and says we
force everybody to apply to history and
randomly assign some people to report
their sex as male so here we see sort of
a different interpretation which is it's
not so much what your gender is but what
do you report and that's sort of
reaffirmed on the next page when he says
women that would be or a woman would be
admitted if she faked her sex torito's
male right but sort of it's pretty clear
that wiggling tweaking misreporting and
faking doesn't seem to be a robust basis
we're talking about you know sensitive
categories and causal modeling okay and
so that's why some people in the causal
community said we can't do that stuff at
all we can't talk about gender or race
as causes okay and maybe the first
explicit articulation of this viewpoint
was Holland in 1986 who wrote put as
bluntly and contentiously as possible
and this article I take the position
that causes are only the things that
could in principle be treatments and
experiments okay and the only way for an
attribute to change its value is for the
unit to change in some way and no longer
be the same unit statements of
that involved attributes as causes
always statements of association between
the values of an attribute and a
response variable across the units and
the population so for holland a
statement like she was rejected because
she was a woman is just a statement like
sort of statistically speaking women are
more likely to get rejected in these
kind of situations so he says these
things are never causal they're always
like statements of association but
sometimes it's sure nice to talk about
race or gender as a cause and so there's
a proposed solution in the community
that it's uh calls the rubin Griner
solution and it goes like this
so instead of talking about race as a
cause you talk about exposure to race as
a cause for instance the name of on a CV
and instead of talking about what
happens to you because of your race you
talk about how decision-makers respond
to stimuli of race okay
and so you will ask questions like how
does a car salesman respond to you know
perceptions of race in like when they
when they sell cars or whatever or how
do decision makers hiring committees
respond to ethnic names and CVS and so
on and then the hope is that exposure to
race is something we can tweak and
wiggle without this embarrassing sort of
interpretation okay that we can say we
can like randomize names and on CBS we
can randomize something and but I find
you know ISA or the husband's critique
quite compelling from her from a paper
and she's gonna talk more about this on
why this is not a solution and why this
is more of a trick that doesn't sort of
address the sociological difficulties
here okay so can we put race in a causal
model is that is that possible is that
something we can do and so when I
thought about this question I actually
had to sort of step it back just take a
step back and ask a more basic question
you know what is a causal model and what
is a model anyway right so this is where
we're gonna ask the really deep you know
philosophical questions in this talk
like you know is it maybe just obey no
prog broccoli and not cauliflower and
you know we'll see so I'm gonna connect
to a point that yiling alluded
I'm gonna try to make a little bit more
explicit that models are systems of
reduced complexity that separate a set
of variables from there possibly chaotic
broader surroundings in the universe and
actually pearl summarized this very
cleverly and and and in a way that I've
found tremendously insightful in its
2009 book he wrote if you wish to
include the entire universe in the model
causality disappears because
interventions disappear the manipulator
and the manipulated lose their
distinction however scientists rarely
consider the entirety of the universe as
an object of investigation in most cases
the scientist carves out a piece from
the universe and proclaims that piece in
namely the focus of Investigation the
rest of the universe is then considered
out or background and is summarized by
what we call boundary conditions this
choice of ins and outs creates a
symmetry in the way we look at things
and it is this asymmetry that permits us
to talk about the outside intervention
and hence about causality and cause and
effect directionality so it's in fact
the boundary box that we draw is what
gives as a notion of causality if you
look at the universe at the atomic level
and evolving according to the laws of
physics there may not be a clear notion
of causality but if you carve out a
piece and you draw a bounding box around
it you could talk about interventions
and that's what gives a causality and so
the question that this leads to and why
I think this is such a good way of
looking at it is what bounding box can
we draw around race and you know what is
race ontologically and epistemologically
complicated because we're going to go
into the ontology of race that is
continues to be unstable and so just to
make the sort of drive home the point
that causal claims implicitly reference
ontology let me give you a few examples
some of them also from ESA's paper
actually so how about this this
statement rain caused the grass to be
wet okay
it's not like this sort of like a
perfectly clear statement right it's you
know I have some I referenced some
implicit you know notion of grass and
rain and what it means to be wet and
maybe I'm not exactly sure what
botanical category a grass is but for
the statement that I'm trying to make it
doesn't really matter what kind of plan
grass is right it doesn't really matter
where it sits in the broader ontology of
plants it's just sort of a very robust
statement that doesn't sort of hinge in
dental code ways on the ontology of
these these things let me give you a few
other examples throwing of the stone
broke the window right you could imagine
somebody like trying to like sort of
hurl lava at a window or something like
that right and you know like you but I
assume that it's actually the rigidity
of the stone here that broke the window
relative to the rigidity of glass right
and these sort of make references to our
understanding of glass and and stones
and windows right and so here's another
one how about witchcraft killed the man
okay who has a nose a movie with like
witchcraft in it where somebody dies
from witchcraft I think I've never
watched what which is a Eastwick
anything else Harry Potter
okay how about Harry Potter I've never
watched Harry Potter but let's suppose
somebody you know was killed in Harry
Potter with witchcraft right if I say
we're watching this movie together and
they say oh witchcraft killed the man
then you find that a perfectly
acceptable statement because I'm making
reference to some implicit ontology of
what witchcraft is that applies to this
movie but I hope you're not going to go
out of the room and say oh there's this
Berkeley professor who things that
witchcraft can kill people right so
right right yeah okay let's not you know
get into that but you know basically
there is you know this statement makes
sense you know when it references a
certain kind of context in an ontology
it doesn't make sense as a universal law
of like death and witchcraft right and
then attention deficit deficit disorder
cost the student to perform worse on the
test there's another interesting example
because that's a new category that was
constructed fairly recently right and
such a statement is not sort of
universal and wouldn't have made sense
at all times and maybe continues to
evolve as we serve update our
understanding of this and so then how
does a statement like she was rejected
because she is black
to this and how do we how do we think
about these statements let me give you
two examples that show you just a
partial view of how different
ontological constructions of race lead
to different modeling choices which then
lead to different insights okay and here
is a first hypothetical ontology it's
basically the way it's typically drawn
in a technical paper on on race and
discrimination you would conceptualize
race as a source note something that you
know it doesn't have any incoming arrows
and what that means the sort of you know
you say well race is a trade that's
present at birth
and that influences various things like
into education health income throughout
the life and as you go through life as
an individual of a certain race things
happen to you you have different access
to opportunity you have a different
educational outcome and so on and so
people draw it that way and that's the
typical way that people might go about
it in technical papers and so in this
view all these variables that education
become mediators between race and the
outcome and the complexity the founder
of that bounding box stuff enters the
picture because I now need to think
about what are all the relevant social
factors that mediate between race and
the outcome what are all the things in
the surrounding social system that I
need to include to have a meaningful
statement about how race influences the
outcome okay and what are all the
pathways in which race can influence the
outcome as you go through life and so
how can you like get a clean model of
that that will be the challenge with
this kind of view but let me give you an
alternative view which is maybe like
closer to serve the social
constructivist account of race that race
is a category that society assigns to
you it's not something that's a sort of
a quasi biological trait it's something
constructed that people categorize you
with and the way you're categorize
changes your behavior in response to the
category and how you change your
behavior in response to the category
depends on various social factors for
instance a Harvard professor might
express raise differently than an artist
or a car mechanic okay so your level of
education might influence how you
express race and so there's actually an
incoming arrow from you know social
factors like education
into race which determine how you
respond to this categorization and how
you express it okay this is interesting
because the error now goes the other way
okay it's AG not this sort of like
biologically sort of inspired trait idea
that it sort of comes as a source node
but it's a category that's placed on you
all right
and I think this perspective might
actually be a little bit closer to
what's called the social constructivist
view of race okay and the problem with
this view is that you now have all these
other variables that you could include
which could also confound this is called
a confounder because it causally
influences both this node and that node
you have to think about all the other
possible confounders that you might have
to include sort of have to pull out of
the social system and include of you
including your model to make sense of
this kind of model okay and so the thing
here is neither of these are meant as
like definitive ontologies of race and
I'm not proposing that this is
necessarily how we should model it my
point is however that in the first
ontology that are presented education
was a mediator education became a meteor
between race and the outcome in the
second one education is a confounder
it's something that influences both the
outcome and the sensitive category and
so again to give you pearl quote as you
surely know by now mistaking a mediator
for a confounder is one of the deadliest
sins and causal inference and may lead
to the most outrageous error the letter
invites adjustment the former forbids it
so this has real sort of pragmatic and
technical import you like mistaking the
two things will lead to just invalid
results okay so it's not you know this
is the point where we can't just pretend
like this is all sort of intent
intellectualizing the subject and it's
not relevant for sort of pragmatic data
science it totally is like you just
simply get invalid results if you get
this wrong so if you model ontology
incorrectly or imprecisely you get wrong
statements wrong interventions okay and
so this is a practical matter after all
and so why is this so complicated to
model the ontology of race and and
included in causal models and I may be
out of time actually but
great but I've just one one one slide
left basically so basically you know
there are two sources of instability
this is from a recent book of Ron Mellon
the construction of humankind's Taylor
and stability refers to changing norms
epistemic activities and theories about
race and then there's a one eye that
quite resonates with me which is hacking
instability that sort of there's a
feedback loop between categories and
individuals that look something like
this and the way you categorize people
changes their behavior and in response
to how they change their behavior your
construction of the category becomes
invalid it needs to be updated so
according to hacking categories are
always moving targets they're never
completely stable and so just to sum up
and give you some pragmatic routes
forward I've been stuck on this topic
for a long time and I don't want people
to stop talking about sensitive
categories in causal analysis I think it
makes sense and to think about how we
can make causal statements about these
things and a lot would be lost if we
could no longer say she was rejected
because she was black and we can't make
sense out of these statements so let me
give you a few pragmatic routes for they
want to discuss with you
there's an idea in Mellon's book called
stable enough ontology so I want to
think about how much you saw how stable
do these things have to be for us to
make certain kind of statements okay
can we somehow get a better
understanding of what kind of stability
we need to allow for certain causal
claims then their philosophy or Nancy
Cartwright has an interesting notion
called single case purpose-built causal
models which are kind of getting into
this idea that causal models do not
encode universal quasi physical laws
about the universe they're actually very
narrowly scoped and you need to think
about what social facts are referenced
implicitly in your model and how you
build sort of context-sensitive models
that might be good for one case once in
an area but not all and then ISA is
probably going to talk more about
consider if explanations and how to
interpret causal explanations as such I
think that's very interesting
Gillian yiling talked essentially about
how you design interventions that might
reduce inequality without talking about
race as a cause or without talking about
gender as a cause so I think there's a
broad range of interventions that you
can
talk about and inequality inequality of
reducing interventions that do not
require us to talk about race as it
calls okay finally and I think Jay is
going to talk about this there's a
wealth of knowledge in the epidemiology
community around health disparities and
race and health disparities and these
folks have figured out a lot of ways of
being creative with modeling race and
health disparities and you should look
into a lot of papers from epidemiology I
think they're a step ahead on this and
it's good to learn from them all right
thank you what is just a broad I really
like that you ended on learning from
practices in epidemiology and other
neighboring fields that have sort of
gone through this process of trying to
think about these things and one of the
places where I think Emma D epidemiology
has ended up thanks to Nancy Krieger and
many others is thinking seriously about
studying racism and not race and so the
black woman wasn't discriminated because
she was black she was discriminated
because of racism and so really shifting
the language I think can get at much
closer to the the actual cause it's not
an inherent quality of the individual
not even that they changed their
behavior and so I wonder if you and
others are have have examples of that
where we're operationalizing racism and
it's interesting that the example of
witchcraft because there's a great book
that I would recommend that people check
out called race craft in which Karen and
Barbara fields actually draw this
parallel between the kind of way in
which witchcraft as a causal world view
can be understood as an as a shaping
race craft in the United States
specifically so if you want to sort of
use that as a touchstone to thinking
about it I would really encourage it
thank you
and pointers I want to return to that
question the panel because I think ISA
and J are going to have a lot to say
about the question of when can you put
racism in a model as opposed to race and
when does it work and what do we get
from it so I'd like to return to that
question the next maker will be J
Kaufman in epidemiology and
biostatistics at McGill University
thanks very much
so yeah I'll try to give the perspective
from bhaiyya
from medicine and epidemiology we use
algorithms all the time in epidemiology
and medical practice trying to decide
trying to use evidence in order to find
optimal treatment strategies diagnostic
strategies to optimize some outcome
however we define it so we have a whole
technology for developing these
algorithms and of course there's some
attention to the fact that they be fair
that they don't involve discrimination
we've discussed in this session over the
last few days that we don't have good
consensus on what it means for an
algorithm to be fair for there to be an
absence of discrimination we have a
bunch of different definitions that
might be in conflict with one another we
might say the algorithm shouldn't rely
explicitly on a protected class like I
shouldn't arrest people because of their
race or because of their gender or I
shouldn't treat people in a certain way
because of their race and gender there's
some kind of direct discrimination like
that and then I could have another kind
of criteria which is that I want some
equality of outcomes like I have to
treat people in such a way so that I
don't have excess cases of disease in
one group or another or excess cases of
incarceration in one group or another
and these can be in conflict with one
another like we have to make some kind
of a societal judgement about how we
weigh these different kind of criteria
so in medicine for example we might it's
considered normative or ethical to
explicitly refer to these protective
protected classes like race or gender in
treatment or screening in order to
equalize outcomes so for example I have
here the
prostate cancer screening guidelines
from the American Cancer Society saying
that men should start prostate cancer
screening at age of 50 but if you're in
a high-risk group which includes black
men then you have to start screening
earlier at 45 the recommendation is
start screening earlier 45 and the goal
there is to well if you screened
everybody at age 50 that it would be
unfair to black men because they would
end up with more cases of advanced stage
prostate cancer at detection or they
would have higher mortality from
prostate cancer so this kind of logic is
that you have to make it unequal in the
screening recommendations so that it can
be equal in the outcome and John's
favorite example John consomme for
example very specific drugs like by dill
same kind of argument if you have a drug
treatment strategy and it seems to
disadvantage one group and you should
explicitly use this protected class in
the assignment of a drug treatment or we
have that also normatively for dosages
of drugs like this ACE inhibitor and the
pack
Lilla Graham if you're non-black and
another 2 milligrams if you're black
alright so this is I'm not promoting or
endorsing this but I'm saying this is
considered normative and ethical within
medical practice that you discriminate
in the sense in a positive sense that
you take notice of these racial groups
in order to try to equalize outcomes
this is the algorithm for deciding on
first stage mono therapy for
hypertension from the British guidelines
I basically go down two paths one if
you're younger and non or non black or
older or black whether you get a syn
addition or beta blockers or going down
the other pathway whether your first
line and hypertensive is calcium channel
blockers or diuretics so again this is
standard practice in a number of
different areas within medicine it yeah
within like policing you you might have
a much stricter criteria about not using
this kind of information but it's
actually promoted within medicine that
this would be the it would be unethical
not to take advantage of this like I
think the if you look at the platform or
the the priorities of the NIH Institute
the National Institute for minority
health and health disparities their
major emphasis is on this kind of
embrace of diversity which means you
know we're all different we have all
these different cultures we've all these
different races within American society
and we all have to be treated in the
kind of precision medicine sense all
differently to respect our wonderful
diversity and this is there very
explicit kind of priority statement
about what their Institute is all about
so this is promoted as a as a virtue
within the field dorothy mentioned sally
Satele writing in The New York Times
saying you know it would be unethical
for me to ignore race and at the same
time of course that this is promoted as
a virtue we have a great deal of medical
evidence that race is used when
physicians clinicians are aware of race
use in very pernicious ways to actually
disadvantage people so
there's it's a two-edged sword in terms
of being aware of this kind of a
classifier within the medical record
that it's actually used in ways that are
are harmful to people that are not
benefiting people overall so we we have
no shortage of evidence that this is in
fact what happens in practice what we
don't really have it though in in
epidemiology and medicine I mean the
last speaker said you should look to
epidemiology for the answer these
questions but it's not really very well
articulated exactly how this kind of
evidence base is created within medicine
and epidemiology we don't really have a
good definition of what it is to be fair
unfair and we don't have a systematic
way as a previous speaker said of taking
into account measured or unmeasured
variables that might explain part of the
disparity that we observe and a
particularly pernicious problem that
I'll discuss in greater detail is how we
take into account previous knowledge
that we have that enters into our
decisions it's based on some previously
unfair situation and people using that
information in a way that seems rational
but perpetuates that that inequality and
then how we use this information in
order to actually eliminate inequalities
which is our goal so continuing with the
previous description this is the sort of
formal causal framework that people use
within epidemiology biostatistics
talking about these things
more it's already put up the the dag
these are directed acyclic graphs as he
described thinking about the protected
class here is X and you have two kinds
of covariates as you mentioned you can
have confounders like Zed and mediators
like W and you make statistical analyses
based on your assumptions as encoded in
this kind of a graph
the only elaborations here is that this
allows the covariate also affect the
mediator the mediators can found it here
or you could have unmeasured confounders
and you have to have identification
under some unmeasured variables as well
as being actually the typical situation
that you have many things that are
unmeasured so as you said we have
effects that can be direct or indirect
and the direct discrimination would be
this this arrow from X to Y as as you
described so this leads to the
construction of a bunch of diff
rent parameters that we might be
interested in in order to detect overt
discrimination or in order to say how
much of a disparity is mediated by some
measured covariance so continuing in the
same technical literature here the total
of the square disparities to subscribe
it is the distribution of Y in one class
compared to the distribution of Y in the
other classes you know the outcome
prevalence and one group compared to the
other group so what's what's the
disparity and breast cancer prostate
cancer between these two groups and then
you could create some kind of a
counterfactual contrast that's what eise
is going to talk about in greater detail
where you say well what would my rate of
prostate cancer be in for a black man if
I had the rate that white people enjoy
alright like this is a very reasonable
thing to do to say like what do we
consider excess cases you know
epidemiology is about epidemics we have
to know what our excess cases how many
prostate cancer is too much well if
blacks have a rate that's higher than
whites those are excess cases that they
are suffering from because they have a
rate that's higher than some reference
group that we can describe to be the
whole population it could be an
advantage subgroup so this effect of the
treatment among it treated the season
this econometrics language is just
describing this kind of counterfactual
quality of quantity which is the rate
that you would expect if you had instead
of the rate that sir actually observed
the rate that would be observed in the
advantage class and then you could do
that conditional on covariance as well
right so you could model this you know
taking into account confounders of these
things makes sense you know we have a
lot of historical confounding you know
african-americans are more likely than
them South the southern part of the
United States has lower life expectancy
than the rest of the United States so
some of the life expectancy difference
is confounded by state of residence
right so it's not historical kind of
confounding so you've taken that into
account and you would estimate this
excess accounting for some and things
like that and then you have the
construction of a mediated quantities
which again the previous speaker started
to get at you have the control direct
effect which is defined as
the the disparity that you would observe
if you set the mediator of particular
values so in his example education how
much of the gap between blacks and
whites and some outcome is due to the
fact that having take educational
disparity well I can model that by
saying what if I forced everybody to get
an equivalent amount or quality of
education and like a model how much of
the disparity is still existing after
taking that into account and then
there's another formulation that's due
to parole and also Jamie Robbins called
this natural direct effect which is a
different quantity instead of setting
the mediator to a specific value you say
I want to know what the disparity would
be if the mediator had the value that it
would have had if you had been in the
protected class you know I want to know
what the black rate of prostate cancer
would be if blacks had the same
educational distribution that whites
have and that's called the natural
direct effect it has some advantages in
interpretation having to do with effect
measure modification but Perl really
likes this formulation promotes this as
the the way that everybody should be
mediation many other people are critical
about this because you can't verify it
in a trial there's no way you can make a
randomized trial in which you assign
people to the value they would have had
if they were somebody else like you
can't you can't actually practically do
that and there are many people Thomas
Richardson and Robbins or argue that
these quantities don't actually exist
that they're complete mathematical
abstractions they have no meaning in the
real world parole has a completely
different opinion the arguments about
whether they're actually identified like
whether you can actually estimate these
things so this is this is an argument
that goes on in the technical literature
it's summarized with specifically with
respect to race in this article by van
der Wiel in which he sets this up with
SES and proposes that you basically take
a control direct effect approach to
asking not what would happen if you set
race right we're not interested in
changing anybody's race as the previous
speaker mentioned but simply control
direct effects for the mediator like
what would happen if we if we gave if we
assign people you know we have
mechanisms for changing people's
educational distribution we have Pell
grants and other kind of policies they
affect people's education distribution
so what would happen if we equalize
there as
through some kinds of intervention how
much of the disparity would still exist
this seems to be a question that you
could ask this actually it was Nancy who
made a nice response to this pointing
out that it's not actually consistent
with our goals like what we really want
to know is not what would happen if we
set everybody's education level or SES
to a certain level that our social
justice goal is really the elimination
of the arrow that connects race to
social class like what do we actually
want to achieve a society is not that we
want to go around setting people's
social status by interventions by policy
interventions but rather that we'd like
to construct a society in which it's no
longer the case that your social status
is determined by your race and that
means that what we're targeting what
we're actually interested in we should
be interested in is this natural direct
effect is this effect if race had no
effect on your of the distribution of
your mediator that that that actually is
is a more logical thing to target okay
so that that's what goes on in in the
technical literature a couple of
applying examples to show how this works
in practice so here's an example of
mediation for gender Cola of just last
month published the study of grants
submitted the Gates Foundation and the
grant review was blinded okay so we know
our priori is we're drawing out that dag
we know that there cannot be an arrow
from gender to grant score because the
evaluators are blinded they don't know
anything about the gender but there was
this big gender disparity so the title
of the article is that blinding wasn't
enough and so they analysed all the
characteristics of the of the grant
applications to see what accounted for
this and it was the use of broad versus
narrow words that men tended to use
broad words and women tend to use narrow
words were broad and narrow defined as
how frequently those words occur in
other grants like men use a word
frequently in a grant that occurs in all
the grants that are submitted whereas
women use words that are much more
specific to their grant and when they
accounted for this then there was no
gender disparity in
interestingly that measure of broad
versus narrow words didn't predict at
all the productivity of the people once
they were funded that was the the use of
broader narrow words was the the
variable that was correlated with gender
which predicted the funding but not the
productivity of the grant okay so that's
an example of complete mediation where
you you had a measured variable and
accounting for that then there was no
disparity anyway that that that
explained entirely the variation that
was observed by gender okay the other
important element of this is a use of
experiment because I'm describing things
in observational data but we often use
experiment in order to identify
discriminate discrimination more
directly so here's an example of another
recent paper by Adams looking at the
rate of the gender disparity in the
price at auction of art and they
analyzed 46 years of art auctions and 2
million transactions at art auctions and
they found that women artists got paid
the value of the art was about 40
percent lower than whites
I'm sorry 40 percent lower than men and
again they looked at a bunch of
different Cove areas the the theme of
the painting this is painted by a woman
it has roses in it women were much more
likely to paint roses and then we're
more likely to paint landscapes that
didn't have roses but when they kind of
heard those things it didn't it didn't
account for the gender disparity so that
the the the adjustment for measured
variables did not contribute so they
were kind of stuck in terms of the
observed data so what they did is a
bunch of experiments so the first thing
they did is to show a bunch of unknown
paintings to people and ask them to
estimate the gender of the artists and
people got 50 50 for the gender so they
they did know better than chance so it
was clear from the experiment that
people could not tell from the painting
the gender of the painter and then they
use computer programs to generate
paintings and then they randomly
assigned them to be listed as male or
female and they got the 40% gap you know
were the ones assigned to be a female
artist were valued less so using the
experiment you can do a much better job
of identifying the causal effect of the
gender of the artist
to the observer but which you can't
identify here and this is the the point
that I wanted to make about the
limitations of experiment here is that
thank you that there's a rational
process here and the first speaker
alluded to this as well that economists
call statistical discrimination which is
that if people know like what is the
value of the artwork it's what people
are willing to pay so if the the person
that the auction knows that women's art
is valued 40 percent lower then they're
gonna use that information to decide
what they think people will pay for this
painting and then it has the value that
they believe that it will have there's
no objective meaning to value is
something assigned by your belief about
willingness to pay so this existence of
this discrimination well makes people
who are not sexist themselves like
they're they're behaving in a rational
way they're using their prior
distribution in order to to estimate the
value of the paintings that includes
that discrimination in their estimation
by the way it was also highly variable
across time and across space this gap
the medical analog to that there's a
bunch of papers that use these kinds of
audit experiments or these kinds of you
know evaluations with fake patients in
order to detect direct discrimination
this paper by Shulman for example had
videotapes of actors black and white
male and female actors reading pace
presentation like a complaint a physical
complaint they show the videos to
cardiologists and they were asked to
decide if the person should be referred
to right heart catheterization and there
was a disparity where black women were
referred last but the interesting thing
is they also asked the physicians to
rate the make-believe patients on a
bunch of other characteristics and you
know the black men for example were low
socioeconomics rated to have lower
socioeconomic status more likely to miss
appointments less likely to comply with
treatment and so again you could say
that this is clearly the causal effect
of race you know in terms of a stimuli
for the rater like when you show the
black actor instead of the white actor
to the cardiologist they attribute this
lower socioeconomic status or this less
likely to comply with treatment and
that's that's racism right you're do
affecting that through this experiment
but the other possibility is that they
have a prior distribution based on their
experience or their beliefs that there's
this difference in socioeconomic status
or in compliance based on race and
gender and they're applying that now the
two problems there one is that they're
their calibration might not be accurate
like they may have a stereotype about
blacks and socioeconomic status or
compliance that may actually be way off
so that's one problem another problem is
that that's based on the average person
a distribution is not based on the
person sitting in front of them right so
you could have you know not everybody
sitting at the mean and you could very
strongly mischaracterize a person by
applying the mean value for the
population to them if you think that
that's the only thing you know about
them all right so my last applied
example because I'm running out of time
here is the one that Dorothy mentioned
on Wednesday as an example this kind of
a problem of statistical discrimination
it's not direct discrimination that's
not racism in the direct sense that you
have racist doctors but it's a racist
algorithm and the way that it
discriminates people by by using a mean
to describe everybody in the population
so this is the problem of glomerulus
open teaching this for 30 years and I
still can't say the word glomerular GFR
can either a filtration rate which is
something that you can't really in for
practical reasons you can't measure
directly right it to measure directly in
a study you have to like feed somebody
some material and then collect all their
pee for 24 hours and carefully measure
the rate at which they're peeing it out
so it's not feasible on a hospital
situation so what we do is we estimated
right you take some measured parameters
and you have a function that's been
developed to estimate this so the first
one was this Cockcroft Gault equation
and then the mdrd equation ad epi and
and then so statin see the one that is
most highly recommended now is the
ckd-epi is the sort of modern one that
everybody's supposed to use the
Cockcroft golfed equation is a little
bit outdated now it does not involve
race its age sex body weight and serum
creatinine these first three are all
based on serum creatinine and it was
developed in about 250 white men and to
apply to women they just assumed
that women would be penalized 15% and
then it would apply to women as well so
it's just this equation and they
observed that the prediction was worse
for african-americans so this led them
the community to decide we need a better
equation that takes race into account
because we have this worse prediction
for african-americans so they develop
this mdrd equation and now you include
race which is just African Americans
versus everybody else in the world and
this is based on 1,600 Americans and
it's an equation here that just has this
black penalty here you get an extra 20%
here if you're black
raising your GFR and then this was
improved a little bit using the same
variables test developed on a larger
data set here that involved a little bit
more diverse populations this is the the
dominant one now that's most highly
recommended and it also uses the same
things the equation but the parameters
are a bit different here in the equation
so now your penalty for black is that
you get into your GFR gets increased by
about you know 16% so it's like tweaking
on that but this is the standard of care
now there's this other alternative which
is sustained and C which does not
involve race because it does not involve
creatinine and so there's no oh yes so I
should say Dorothy mentioned this too
the explanation for why you need this
for race is has to do with the relation
between creatinine and muscle mass and
the assertion that because blacks have
more muscle mass this is why you need to
create a adjust for this Sosa stanton c
does not rely on muscle on creatinine
and so there's no relationship and it's
found that you don't need to take into
account race when you use this measure
but it's not widely used in practice and
the explanation that I found was that it
is affected by things like smoking and
they said well it's really hard to know
if someone's really a smoker and how
much they smoke it's too complicated
race is very simple you just look at
them you know what race they are but
smoking is a complicated thing you
didn't really know that so I I don't
exactly know and maybe it's a more
expensive I'm not sure it is recommended
as a kind of a like if you have some
clinical uncertainty you're supposed to
order this test but it's not widely used
and it could be and then we wouldn't
a specific one um other countries have
said yeah it's yes why couldn't you just
use the first score but some correction
has just based on muscle mass correctly
it's it clinically it's not easy to
measure muscle mass either like it's
it's not something you can do it in
studies but again it's not at the
bedside it's not an easy thing to
estimate you I'm sure you have better
I'll talk about this in a second I'm
sure you have better proxies for muscle
mass than race but we don't know the
direct measure when you look at somebody
you'd get a rough estimate that's
probably much better than you get from
race yeah this is exactly what I'll talk
about so other countries by the way have
rejected this and they said like in our
populations we don't need to apply this
this is the French document saying it
actually says you should not apply this
black correction to black people in
France but we don't know what you should
do with them this is from 2011 so I
don't know what's happened since then
but they just say warning people like
don't do you know if you see a black
person in france don't apply this thing
because it doesn't work for them and
likewise i found similar things is from
brazil and they said look we did a
validation study and this race
correction doesn't do anything in brazil
so don't use this and i found another
one in England that says the same thing
so I can't find any other place outside
of the United States or Canada where
like people have embraced this race term
and it specifically says African
Americans it doesn't say black people
it's African Americans only that get
this correction and then it's compared
to everybody else in the world yeah
so Nancy just showed me this this came
out in JAMA yesterday June 6th and JAMA
here you see against measured GFR here
here's the black penalty you know the
number of GFR units that you you get
increased if you're black this is the
cut point for being eligible for kidney
transplant and so there's no doubt that
people are disadvantaged by having their
score raised across some cut point like
this like if you're just at the cuff
point you get your score raised you're
gonna be disadvantaged in terms of where
you get on the wait list what is the
practical implication of that this is
from another paper in 26
this is the time you spend on the wait
list waiting for a kidney if you're
black versus if you're white this is
twice as high if you're black than if
you're white I don't know I have I mean
I just put this together for this talk I
haven't looked to see like if you be
doing analysis what proportion of the
variation and wait time is accounted for
the GFR difference I I'm sure you could
estimate that but if it clearly matters
it clearly makes a difference if you're
near the cut point so this question that
you just raised like this is used as a
proxy I was interested like how good of
a proxy is how much of the variation in
in muscle mass is accounted for by race
I couldn't find that anywhere in the
literature I went to n Haynes
and did the analysis because there you
have the dual x-ray absorb atomic
absorbed by AMA tree for muscle mass so
you can see and this is a distribution
of whites and blacks it is true in the N
Haynes data anyway that the black mean
is significantly higher than the
whitening but it's also true that if you
know that a person is black or white you
have almost no additional information
about what their individual muscle mass
is right and so to treat people
categorically just hey you know like
Spike Lee walks into your clinic and
Arnold Schwarzenegger walks into your
clinic and you say oh Spike Lee you have
more muscle mass like this is just
absolutely ridiculous like it just
doesn't make any sense and yet this is
exactly what normative medical practice
is saying about these variables like you
you have to do so to give a kind of
absurd example of this I'm about to take
the red-eye tonight so I'd really like
to be in one of these exit seats because
then you can put your legs out and
really spread out how does the airline
assign these exit seats in a fair way no
they sell them right so you have to
actually discrimination for rich people
right but what would a fare algorithm be
well a fair algorithm would be if you're
tall you should get the exit seat
because you have more legs like you you
need that space like a fair society
would assign the exit row to taller
people but the airline doesn't know how
tall you are when you buy your ticket
they know how rich you are right but
they don't know how tall you are so they
could have an algorithm because when you
check-in to get your airline ticket you
have to check your your birth date and
your gender right so
they know whether you're a man or a
woman and they can have a rule that says
men always get the exit row and why do
men always get the exit row because men
on average are taller than women just
about like this right and so they would
be rational in the sense that because
there's a significant difference in the
mean here you are making a rational
judgment by always giving the exit row
to men but it means when this I mean
these two people show up to get on the
airline you're gonna say to the woman no
you're not allowed to sit there because
you're shorter and when we can say well
I'm obviously not shorter and you say
well but you belong to a group which is
shorter on average and therefore I'm
going to treat you like you're at the
center at the mean of your distribution
and that is discriminatory for that
individual because people are not all at
the mean of their distribution and
that's a kind of unfairness as well to
be treated at the mean from a
distribution there's a big statistical
literature or economic econometrics
literature about the statistical
discrimination which also talks about
the the varying width of that
distribution for blacks and for whites
and how more blacks are farther from
their mean because of clinical
uncertainty and things like that and so
this this aspect becomes important ok so
that's that's what I wanted to say I
think I'm over time it should be
considered unethical to use a weak proxy
like this like well I say it should not
be considered ethical to use a weak
proxy like this like this idea like I'm
gonna categorically treat blacks and
whites different in this way because the
difference in the average I'm sure I
didn't do it yet but I'm sure I can go
in and Hanes and come up with 20
variables that are available the bedside
that are better predictors of muscle
mass I mean not to mention you can just
look at somebody and have a better idea
then you could get by taking into
account their race and so it's
absolutely absurd this framework that we
use in causal entrants for direct and
indirect effects has some advantages and
has this experimental foundation that
you could do experiments in order to
test for this direct discrimination but
it doesn't do very well for this kind of
statistical discrimination that's
involved in like what you know
previously about people and what
assumptions you make about distributions
that people come from okay thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]